außerdem verdienten stelligen bereich
werde mit sicherheit bekommen wir heute
bei einem neuen video von dem mittel
eingependelt ihre häuschen auf dumme
kommentare hab ich kenne ich schon lange
nicht mehr gemacht
internet ist ein ort an dem wir
gerechnet während uwe hartwig
verbreitete in liebe und lebe ich
eigentlich ich habe einfach mal die
kommentare durch gebet und meinen
glänzen hochgeladenen video und hat dann
unter jedem video meister 12 kommentare
ausgenommen und haben irgendwie es
bestimmte sachen gesucht doch nicht
einfach mal reagieren wollten wir zeigen
wollte unsere mit dem namen jane morris
bezwungene only looking for quick
bags.de du hier sein google.com danke
für deinen kommentar englmar du bitte
verpiss dich von meinem kanal
das ist ja allgemein sorge sagte also
ich verstehe eigentlich früher konnte
man bei youtube keine link für die
kommentare postet einfach würde meinen
kommentar bestehen hatte man haus dann
links rein und bildet porsche design
geht nicht weil man linken hat aber
mittlerweile ist es möglich linkedin
kommentare zu posten youtube wunderbar
wer denkt sich bei euch dass das eine
gute idee ich habe da lösungsvorschlag
und welches team von youtube ich weiß
wer mich dass die websites so gut ist
wie sonst aber könnt ihr nicht einfach
wachen dass nur der urheber des videos
einen link in den kommentarbereich
werden video worten kann er eigentlich
ganz ganz cool oder der beste head for
iphone in die elbe werben
dieser kommentare unter dem video wo ich
euch zehn iphone lite weg vorgestellt an
dem ich dabei darunter hinter dem namen
blogs erscheinen der meinung dass man
das iphone einfach in einen luftwerte
lebendig das wollen wir doch mal den
deutschen wird es auf jeden fall direkt
der erste live act sei viel zu wenig
wow
wow ich bin gekränkt in meinen ganzen
immer im tiefsten herzen dass irgendwann
warum warum schreibt man so war sie hat
er muss eigene leben sein wenn man sowas
frei
taylor er hat mit dating angefangen und
jetzt ist er eine blonde ab von den
usern netzwerk ins spiel
er hat sich da auf einen feurigen
kommentaren bogen geht aber leider nicht
mehr finden konnte
ich weiß nicht was da geschrieben wurde
auf jeden fall meint der user hat dass
ich eine gaming angefangen habe war
natürlich stimmt also ich habe mit
gaming angefangen und jetzt bin ich ein
blonder abu raed geworden wie und dafür
die entwicklung bestätigt mein leben
darauf dass sich mit gaming angefangen
habe und dann mich entwickeln haben für
einen blu ray schlecht oder cloud trend
aus amerika oder was bin ich
nein ich versteh ich das sind ja auch
nur viele leute mittlerweile den
kommentaren die mir schreiben dass die
coolsten gaming gemacht werden wenn sie
noch nicht mehr du hier und versteht
mich nicht falsch ich hab eigentlich
will ich gar nicht mitmachen ein
community berichtet nicht wirklich nur
die leute die mich anscheinend ja früher
nur gekocht haben weil es gekocht habe
und vom typ verändert habe ich mich
nicht über oder ich mich weniger kennt
mittlerweile hoch war doch ein paar ich
mach ja immer noch gemeinsam ein letzten
vier ein video war auch bei 3 video game
wo ich beispielsweise goleta oder die
katzen spiel gespielt habe es muss
eigentlich richtig sagen bei denen ich
studiere und seitdem ich halt den ganzen
lärm stress und so nebenher noch abend
einfach sein die von den kamera zu
stellen und vom stil her einfacher und
gehen hat mich früher gesagt natürlich
gar nicht mehr mithalten
in frieden fängt auch von bitten mit
meiner gesundheit zusammen also ich
werde mal auf meinen vater darüber reden
den verlinkt ich euch mal hier oder da
da da glaube ich damals bei kanal
verlinkt ich bin der fällt nicht so ganz
gesund und dafür hängt auch zusammen
also ich möchte solche kommentare nicht
mehr wählen aber ich werde darüber auch
keine rede
ja wir machen weiter mit den kommentaren
vielen pullover aus du kannst nicht mal
den viel von den kickflip unterscheiden
wer fährt der user mit der hand
geschrieben und er meint sieben treffer
magazine pullover und der augen der
sache nicht überhaupt überstehen kann
die mit wissen das diabolo war von einem
magazinen für gay potter in und die
produktion noch andere skateboard
klamotten und so nah und alles mögen
schon die therapien ihren bleibe aber
und ich glaube jeder der sich ein
bisschen mit mode ist irgendwelche
modetrend beschäftigt weiß dass dieser
pullover ein bisschen enthält genau die
performance von das viva die allgemeine
lohnniveau an die allgemeinen gibt
berufen
das sind derzeit mode und deswegen kaufe
nicht geleugnet überhaupt nicht mit
diesem treffer magazine und das geld
ordentlich zu tun haben die klamotten
von dieser marke ist einfach cool
aussieht und bei dem jeder trainer muss
jetzt allerdings die sache die ich nicht
verstehe und überfährt auch von 23
freundin von mir dann sagen wenn ich
leute sie ihr licht schwächer bei
olivetti paroli bot
da hat man entwickelt keine frage weil
er einem gefällt oder also lieber wieder
mit dem namen handfeste warst du der
hippie klamotten die ich gerne tragen
möchte wenn die mir gefallen und ich sag
ja auch nicht bei der wm für jemanden
geprägten deutschland-trikot
wittenschwand die wut bei den verein
gespielt sagte auch nicht wie man der uk
gehört afghanistan wurde der kalender
konnten gefallen nicht
ich will nicht ewig kommentar löschen
lässt einfach peinlich eine meinung zu
haben finde ich heute diesem video gar
nicht
aber ein paar läufer hat sie geritten
wenn man sowas frei an alle anderen wird
was ich mag und mit hey das ist ja auch
wo ich meine videos machen 99 prozent
positive bewertungen und ich nicht ob
der positive feedback aber es half mir
winziger für die kosten für zweiten wir
kommentieren solche mit dem
dreistelligen bereich verdienen
okay wir haben einen konter von dem user
dort der mario gattiker offen also
erstmal lade ich deiner meinung nach
wird nicht etwa im angeklagt sind vier
geschmackssache wollen
mit bissig hielt dann benutzt ja in
ordnung dann gern beck guckst du dich an
und werden alle handy aber selbst der
andere leute mögen das was ich mache und
jetzt sagst du halt auch noch für so
einen mist verdiene ich im dreistelligen
bereich also dreistelliger bereich ist
ein sehr geringer verdient der
durchschnittsverdienst in deutschland
liegt bei 2.000 jedenfalls oder so
selbst dafür schon vierstellig also
diese aussage machte etwa nicht so ganz
hin wenn die sachen die man schaut
macht- und dementsprechend viel
verdienen damit eine hohe zahl
reinwerfen also dass es nicht so klug
geschrieben hat aber wenn du mein konnte
nicht mag dann mussten die einen
anschaulichen bereit bist einfach nur
einen click kleiner und kleiner youtuber
geworden ich traurig was mit youtube
deutschland hat hier also wenn ihr euch
weil video von anderen roten youtube an
anzahl die da sagen das ist meine morgen
routine und dann irgendwas wird auch mit
intel das überhaupt nicht oder überhaupt
nicht im video programm blablabla
sie ist auch als die wehrleute video die
normalerweise nur vier minuten gehen
dann einfach im stadtbild einfügen und
offingen strecken so dass die werbung
schalten
können aber was mache ich denn falsch so
großartig mein okay ich lade auch auf
video hoch die irgendwie elf minuten
gehen oder so ruhig dann natürlich meine
mit werbung schalten und natürlich noch
kein waisenkind in großbuchstaben und
natürlich machen wir mit aufgaben wie
schnell ich auch die aber das macht
jeder und ich will mich doch auch nicht
in gute licht rücken
aber ich finde ich mache das noch in der
abgeschwächten form guckt euch zum
beispiel die wird heutige video an also
im titel steht ich wäre dumm kommentare
vor oder sie reagiere darauf als 100
prozent die wahrheit
ich lese dumme kommentare bord reagiere
darauf ich weiß nicht was das sein wird
aber wahrscheinlich einfach wie ich
lache oder vordrucke und mit einem
kommentar daneben und das ist einfach
nur das was in ihrem video auch passiert
ich weiß nicht wie lange dieses video
gehen wir aber wenn es über zehn minuten
gehen wir dann werde ich natürlich auch
mit werbung schalten weil ich
dementsprechend auch länger im schnitt
und meiner meinung nach mache ich jetzt
wirklich noch relativ harmlosen content
was das andere youtuber angeht die
irgendwie mit messern ihre
wertgegenstände zerschneiden und alles
mögliche als wirklich weiß nicht wie ihr
meine mails zuschauer darüber denkt ich
würde mich echt war darüber
interessieren findet ihr ich bin jemand
der wenig sorgen im norden schlechtes
beispiel youtube dörfern oder
konvertieren oder sie können auch gerne
hart ein also schreibt mir bitte einfach
in die kommentare aber lieber immer mit
dem namen fat ich würde mich jetzt nicht
als klicken und überhaupt nicht eine fan
guide bezeichnen aber wie gesagt dass
sich auch wieder an gewicht betrachter
weiß ich ganz genau wie das heißt diese
redewendung trotzdem ändert seine
meinung es ist in ordnung ich würde die
nicht so zu sprechen aber immer weiter
ich habe wirklich alle riesig und bin
nicht so alt wie du video per kommentar
oder unter einem video vom hier gepostet
wo ich irgendwann christ gemacht habe
meine ich und die person meiner liegt
wie man dieses quiz schaffen kann ich
weiß nicht mehr genau was das filmquiz
war aber es hat auf jeden fall nicht mit
dem einsatz zu tun hätte das weiß nichts
über die webseiten sport wo man sagt
okay
jetzt fand die jähriger märkte
zehnjährige oder irgendwie so weit
sondern das war ein wirklich was
irgendwie youtube damit hinter oder zu
tun hatte tut mir leid ich würde in
ihrem video hier gar nicht die ganzen
kommentare irgendwie hochnehmen und die
kommentarschreiber beleidigen oder so
also verstehen ich damit nicht falsch
ich weg nur selber lief gerade
vermitteln so rüberkommen dafür geben
kommentare hier und habe so ein bisschen
war so kann die beiden stunden als er
die heißen den gewährten spricht heute
aber auch ich hab mir ein kommentar aus
wird wo ich mir gedacht okay
das verstehe ich jetzt nicht so ganz wie
man sowas schreiben kann und wollte
einfach meine meinung dazu sagen vielen
dank luca wir haben uns köstlich
amüsiert eines unserer antworten die
favoriten hilfe monaten jetzt
tatsächlich kein dummer kommentar
arbeitet einfach nur zu teilen
das video gemacht habe und die das video
gesehen habe wie ihr vielleicht will
habe ich vor einiger zeit ein video
hochgeladen den ich mich geschminkt habe
gründen
und ich hab das ganze mit einer klappe
aufgemacht also das war aber auch kein
statement ich bekomme gerade auch kein
geld für das video kein geld bekommen
ich hab einfach eine glocke bock
irgendwie bekommen dass da einfach dass
ein haus gepaart mit den innereien davon
quasi geschminkt und die bilden will von
glock die worte wohl ein video gesehen
total gefehlt habe mit der schminke und
an cool ich weiß nicht ob die lügen doch
die das eigentlich fanden aber es tut
mir leid wenn ich eure produkte dreck in
folge haben kann
und wenn dein gewicht da er weil ich den
störe meine videos dadurch dass ich mich
zeigen
laut seiner meinung nach mit meinem
video aus dem halo war dabei ist luca
bekommen wir neue video ich störe ich
oder kamera weil das kaputte welt
gewichtheber foxi samt mir leid dass du
mein gewicht werden muss aber du kannst
du das video einfach minimieren dann
hört nur meine stimme in der sache
wurden per mail geschickt und war
war nicht nur dumme arbeiten wollen und
auch mal ganz kurz zeigen hey willst du
du luu kein klappern vom vater im himmel
durch das die folgende orte die mail
unter deren sich unternehmen und
kooperation vor liebhaber in zentral
kontaktieren können findet man auf
meinem kanal irgendwo relativ weit
versteckt das heißt wenn man mir
wirklich eine mail schreiben möchte da
muss man schon gehörig suchen und dann
fliegt diese mail von dieser person und
wie fragt mich in der welt den beeten um
diese zu bekommen
doch im kanal wählen dann der in pula
hohenberg nachkochen test bestehen mail
schreiben in der nächste auch noch mein
abi will monat war sie mich tatsächlich
contra verbinden wie mir eine mail frei
der das was sie von mir meine damen und
herren ich hoffe ich dort in irgendeiner
form erhalten möchte thun konnte der
langsam leid da und wenn die leute einen
pilz dazu gehören butzbach wenn ihr
unterbrochen gassmann netten kommentare
brad pitts es findet eine trophy
abonnieren
es kommt nur verpackt keine videos mehr
ohne hierfür den anderen video
eingeblendet klickt einfach mal drauf